hello there welcome to world news asian
stocks dived to three year lows on
monday following big falls on Wall
Street last week chinese shares took a
pounding as concerns grow that the
economy there is in trouble investors
are worried the problems in China will
lead to a global economic slowdown where
we can speak now to Patrick Magee a
journalist for the Financial Times in
Hong Kong morning to you Patrick I bet
you've not seen many smiling faces this
morning there no not many this this this
is a staggering sell after day how bad
is it so China's benchmark stock index
is down to eight and a half percent it's
wiped out all of its 2015 games the
stock market in Taiwan has fallen by
seven and a half percent that's its
biggest selloff since 1990 and commodity
prices on average are at their lowest
price since 1999 so let's talk about a
global economic slowdown I mean that is
not just talk this could happen oh yes I
mean certainly china is the world's
second-largest economy and many people
don't actually trust the numbers when
when beijing says they're going at seven
percent per year and they have all the
more reason to believe that now because
two weeks ago China devalue the renminbi
and try to give more markets more more
sense to markets as to how it will be
determined and it's fallen a little bit
since then and the the underlying reason
people tend to think is that China
understands more more than we do that
its economy really is slowing and so
they're taking action and it shows just
how much the US economy really does
relate to what happens in China it is
this fall just solely down to what
happened on Wall Street last Friday do
you think we really have a negative
feedback loop so if I was to explain
friday I would actually point back to
China and so if I was to explain today I
might point back to the US so we have to
find a bottom at some point but there
was no new data today really that made
things any worse it really was just
reaction to Friday so negative feedback
loop I think would be the main headline
here but if they keep sort of following
each other round in a circle it just
keeps going down and down and down what
is going to stop it eventually a very
good question investors will find value
at some point right now we're at the
lunch break for China markets and it is
quite possible that the People's Bank of
China or some other Authority in Beijing
will announce some sort of measure
up the market it was very surprising
today that people woke up having having
six having thought that maybe Beijing
would have enacted some actions over the
weekend to help shore up the market
instead they didn't do anything and that
just had people fearing the worst that
maybe Beijing is no longer basing its
credibility on where the market trades
and if they're not doing that then you
better take your profits now so markets
are still up in China over the course of
the last year but all of 2015 games have
been wiped away people angry with the
Chinese with the Chinese authorities
therefore not making it later making
more room what moves um very good
question because if you go to the FT
calm right now you can see that an
exchange operator not for the main
exchange but for one of the smaller ones
was actually mobbed by people so yes I
mean this is a very retail driven market
China's market is less driven by fund
managers like you would see in the
Western world and more by mom-and-pop
investors who you know have a normal job
and then spend some of the lunch hour
putting in orders so yes definitely the
People's Bank of China and Beijing
basically had a propaganda last autumn
saying that people should be buying
stocks and that this was the way for
wealth creation and and now it looks as
though Beijing is sort of given up that
hope because they decided to fight a
losing battle and prop up a market that
was really in bubble territory according
to all sorts of analysts um it didn't
look like they could win it when they
began taking unprecedented action in
July and it really looks like it's
Beijing versus the market and right now
aging is not winning I know it's
impossible to predict the markets but
based on what you just told us about
this loop what do you think's going to
happen over the next few days presumably
it's going to be bad news right I cannot
see Beijing standing back and doing
nothing I think they have to do
something there's a lot of firepower
that the People's Bank of China has in
terms of cutting more interest rates
they could do that several times over
that there's definitely mean they have
the power they have forex reserves the
money to put a floor into this market
and to instill confidence it really is
surprising that they haven't done
anything yet that I think there's a
decent chance that it's happening right
now during the lunch break and so within
the next hour there could be an
announcement if there's not the market
will just keep following you would think
that the market would be incomplete free
fall and the only reason it's not it's
down eight-point-five percent is that
there's a downward limit of 10 percent
so the mark
actually can't go beyond that so you
know you could say the good news is that
the mark can only fall 1.5% more today
and that gives Beijing an extra day to
think about things but you know the
long-term view right now is a few days
as you say i don't think i can really
forecast what we're going to be like on
friday but i would expect some sort of
stimulus from beijing okay Patrick Magee
therefore the Financial Times in Hong
Kong thanks for your time and we will
continue to watch this what is it three
hours now just under three hours to the
footsie opens here in London several
more hours till the US markets open we
will continue to follow them although as
we were saying they're probably doesn't
look like it's going to be good news in
the short term at least